[Music]  when Luke and dak are flying the  snowspeeders oh lord have mercy  any person well two favorite moments can  I have two I love you I know I like that  I like that moment the first one was the  the big spaceship coming over your head  at the beginning and ever sowed for a  new home  yeah between Hanalei aversion to that  smoosh whatever reason I always  gravitate towards the meeting of Han  Solo r2d2 in in the desert canyons  they're just being zapped by the Javad  range yeah what a huge laughs that one  you take pleasure in r2d2 zapping he  wasn't tempted the moments I always  bring it with me Star Wars are kind of  is early like Cantina moments with the  crazy groovy music and all the creatures  and the trash compactors every time I  give an answer like this I start to  think of literally a dozen scenes I'm  like well that's the very answer so  there isn't  [Music]  you  you